yeah I I want to be humbled I want to
see the video and think yes that is that
well because you know I have a a little
bit of respect I have some respect
actually for Real Models yeah now I'm
not I know nowadays they're all IG
models but I'm like you know I used to
watch America's Next Top Model like some
of that stuff looks kind of hard all the
POS like you're supposed to be the
epitome of like elegance and Grace and
now they've just let just a joke is it
like imagine if they let average
basketball players into the
NBA like the Victoria be secret used to
be the NBA a right and now they just let
they're like you get in they're like
Oprah you get in